THAT WAS AN EXPEDITED 60. WE'VE
GONE OVER SO MANY TIMES. I THINK
WE GO UNDER THIS TIME. SO GOOD
AFTERNOON. THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD AFTERNOON. WE HAVE TWO
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA. THE
SENATE BILLS HAVE BEEN PULLED
BACK FOR HEARING BECAUSE THEY
WERE SUBSTANTIALLY AMENDED IN
THE ASSEMBLY. THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME THE CONTENTS OF THESE BILLS
WILL BE HEARD IN THE SENATE. WE
DO HAVE A QUORUM. WE DO NOT SEE
A QUORUM. LET'S BEGIN THE
SUBCOMMITTEE WITH THE FIRST
BILL. AND WE WELCOME. SENATOR
WILK WILL BE TESTIFYING OR
PRESENTING A BILL ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR PORTANTINO. YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIRMAN. AND COMMITTEE.
COMMITTEE MEMBER, SB 691 WILL
WAS AMENDED IN THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS
THREATENING LANGUAGE RELATED TO
STUDENT TRUANCY NOTICES.
CURRENTLY, THE FIRST NOTICE A
PARENT OR GUARDIAN RECEIVES
ABOUT A STUDENT'S TRUANCY
INCLUDES THE THREATS OF
PROSECUTION OF BOTH THE PARENT
AND STUDENT RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
A POSITIVE PROBLEM SOLVING
APPROACH TO TRUANCY IS MORE
EFFECTIVE THAN PUNITIVE, STATE
MANDATED LEGAL. A LEGAL LANGUAGE
AND A STUDY CONDUCTED IN
CALIFORNIA FOUND THAT REWRITING
TRADITIONAL TRUANCY
NOTIFICATIONS THAT REMOVE
LEGALISTIC LANGUAGE INCREASE
NOTIFICATION EFFECTIVENESS.
EFFECTIVENESS BY 40%. SB 691
ENCOURAGES A MORE COLLABORATIVE
APPROACH BY ALLOWING THE
APPROPRIATE SCHOOL STAFF TO
DISCUSS SOLUTIONS WITH THE
STUDENT AND FAMILY THAT WILL
ADDRESS THEIR TRUANCY. FOR THESE
REASONS, ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
PORTANTINO, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU TO VOTE AYE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT? ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE? LET'S
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. ANY
SORRY. IS THERE ANYBODY HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE? ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NO OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. CORDELL LET'S COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE, COMMENTS?
QUESTIONS? GOT A MOTION FROM
SENATOR CORTEZ. YEAH WE'VE GOT
TO HAVE A QUORUM FIRST. OH,
WELL, BUT HE WILL MOVE IT WHEN
APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE THAT, MR. PORTILLO.
YEAH, WELL, WE HAVE A
PROSPECTIVE MOTION. ALL RIGHT.
WELL, THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
SENATOR WILK. THAT WAS AWFULLY
NICE OF YOU TO DO. AND AT SUCH
TIME AS WE HAVE A QUORUM, WE
WILL ACCEPT THE MOTION FROM
SENATOR CORTEZ, AND WE WILL VOTE
ON THIS MEASURE. ALL RIGHT. WE
WERE MAKING GOOD TIME OVER IT
NOW. AWESOME DID YOU SAY I SENT
YOU AN EMAIL WITH SOME UPDATED
ANSWERS? OH. HOW INTERESTING.
WHO IS HERE? SHE CAN ANSWER THE
QUESTION. VERY GOOD. THAT'S ME.
GOOD. YES CULTURAL. BENJAMIN. IT
WAS ALL RIGHT.
YEAH I GOT.
I FEEL LIKE I SHOULD HAVE SENT
SIT FOR A MOMENT JUST TO SENATOR.
WELCOME. WE ACTUALLY. WE'RE AT
THAT POINT, THE AGENDA IN OUR
TWO BILL AGENDA. YOU'RE THE
SECOND BILL, SO WELCOME, SIR,
AND WELCOME TO YOUR WITNESS
ACROSS THE HALL. INFORMACIÓN
WE'LL HAVE WE'LL HAVE A MOMENT.
YEAH. I WANTED TO GIVE YOU THAT
MOMENT OF QUIET REFLECTION THAT
WE THAT WE TALK ABOUT AND I ALSO
WANT TO NOTE, I WANT TO SAY HI
TO JULIE. JULIE, MISSOURI. IF
SHE'S WATCHING. HI, JULIE, OKAY.
SO FEEL FREE. YOU WILL BE
PRESENTING YOUR MEASURE, AND I
AM LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING
IT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MISTER
CHAIR, THIS BILL, SB 1440,
AUTHORIZES THE STONY CREEK JOINT
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT TO
OPERATE ON A FOUR DAY SCHOOL
WEEK UNTIL THE END OF THE 2028,
2029 SCHOOL YEAR. THIS
AUTHORIZATION CURRENTLY EXISTS
FOR A VERY FEW DISTRICTS. ONE OF
THEM IS IN MY SENATE DISTRICT IN
BIG SUR. STONY CREEK IS SMALL
AND REMOTE. IT ENROLLS BETWEEN
80 TO 90 STUDENTS. OVER HALF OF
THE STUDENT BODY ARE MEMBERS OF
THE GRINDSTONE INDIAN RANCHERIA
OF THE WINTUN WAILAKI INDIANS,
WHICH REGULARLY ENGAGES IN
CULTURAL PRACTICES AND
TRADITIONS DURING THE WEEKDAY.
FAMILIES EXPERIENCE CHALLENGES
ALSO MAKING MEDICAL
APPOINTMENTS, WHICH ARE ALSO
OFTEN AVAILABLE DURING THE
WEEKDAY AND LOCATED IN OTHER
TOWNS. BOTH OF THESE ARE FACTORS
CONTRIBUTING TO THE DISTRICT'S
CHRONIC ABSENTEE LEVELS AND A
LOSS OF LEARNING FOR STUDENTS.
THIS WILL ALLOW US TO ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES THAT STILL THE
DISTRICT WOULD STILL BE REQUIRED
TO MEET MINIMUM INSTRUCTIONAL
STANDARDS, REACH AN AGREEMENT
WITH THEIR BARGAINING UNITS,
MAINTAIN ACADEMIC STANDARDS, AND
PROVIDE MEALS ON ALL FIVE DAYS
UPON REQUEST, THERE WERE, THIS
WAS A LATE BILL, AND THERE WAS
CONCERN IN THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION. THEY HAVE SINCE
SINCE REACHED AN AGREEMENT OR IN
ACCORD WITH THIS DIRECTION. AND
AS A RESULT, THIS BILL HAS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION. AND I
DEBATED WHETHER TO STEAL THE
THUNDER OF THE SUPERINTENDENT,
WHO IS THE WITNESS WE ALREADY
HAVE, BECAUSE THE CHAIR ASKED
TWO QUESTIONS AND SHE IS READY
TO ANSWER THEM REALLY DIRECTLY.
AND I THOUGHT I COULD DO IT IN
MY OPENING STATEMENT. BUT I
THINK I'M GOING TO LET THAT GO.
SO AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME I
WOULD REQUEST AND I VOTE THERE'S
NO REGISTERED OPPOSITION IN
HERE. TO EXPRESS SUPPORT AS THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE DISTRICT.
WELL, WELCOME, SUPERINTENDENT,
HOW LONG DID YOU TRAVEL TO GET
HERE, JUST ABOUT AN HOUR AND 45
MINUTES. AND IT HASN'T SPOILED
IT TOO BADLY FOR YOU. GOOD. NO.
ALL RIGHT. GOOD. IT HASN'T
RENDERED YOUR TRIP UNPRODUCTIVE.
SO WELCOME YOU HAVE GIVE OR TAKE
TWO MINUTES. WE'RE NOT IN A
RUSH. WELL, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME THIS AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS EMILY PENDLE. I AM THE
SUPERINTENDENT PRINCIPAL OF THE
STONY CREEK JOINT UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. WE ARE A VERY TINY
SCHOOL DISTRICT LOCATED IN THE
RURAL MOUNTAINS OF GLEN AND
COLUSA COUNTIES. THIS YEAR,
WE'RE SERVING 60 STUDENTS. TÊ K
THROUGH 12TH GRADE. AND THAT
REPRESENTS 32 FAMILIES IN OUR
COMMUNITY, AS THE SENATOR SAID,
WE SERVE A VERY UNIQUE
POPULATION OF STUDENTS. OVER
HALF OF THEM ARE NATIVE
AMERICAN, AND WE HAVE SOME
CHALLENGES IN OUR DISTRICT
BECAUSE WE'RE SO RURAL. AND SO
WE'RE LOOKING FOR A UNIQUE
SOLUTION TO OUR UNIQUE
CHALLENGES THERE UP IN THE
HILLS. AND THAT'S HOW WE'VE COME
ACROSS FOUR DAY SCHOOL WEEK. SO
I AM READY AND WILLING TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT THE COMMITTEE
HAS REGARDING OUR BILL. I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE SO READY,
SENATOR. YES, I THOUGHT SHE WAS
GOING TO ANSWER THEM IN HER
STATEMENT, BUT WE ARE READY IN
CASE YOU HAVE ANY. I ACTUALLY, I
HAVEN'T READY, BUT WE'LL JUST
TOUCH ON THEM. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE? IF SO, PLEASE COME
FORWARD. ON BEHALF OF THE SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION.
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, MR.
SCHNEIDER. ANYBODY ELSE? DUSTY
THOMPSON, CBO, GLENN COUNTY
OFFICE OF ED. APPRECIATE THAT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE? IF SO, COME FORWARD.
SEEING NONE, LET'S COME BACK.
COME BACK TO THE DAIS. ANY
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS COLLEAGUES?
THE SUPERINTENDENT I DO
APPRECIATE I ASKED THE QUESTION.
I REALLY HAD TWO QUESTIONS. ONE
WAS, YOU KNOW, TO WHAT EXTENT
HAVE ALL FAMILIES BEEN APPRIZED
OF OR CONSULTED? I THINK YOU
SAID 31 OUT OF 32 IS PRETTY
GOOD. I'M TEMPTED TO ASK YOU,
WHAT ABOUT THAT 32ND? BUT IT'S
OKAY, BUT AND THEN I DID HAVE A
CONCERN THAT ON THE FIFTH DAY
FOR THOSE THOSE FAMILIES THAT
WEREN'T MEMBERS OF THE TRIBE AS
TO WHETHER OR NOT, YOU KNOW,
THAT TIME WAS ACCOUNTED FOR AND
OTHERWISE RESOURCE PROVIDER, I
THINK YOU'VE ANSWERED THAT
QUESTION PRETTY WELL. SO
ADDITIONAL ACTIVITIES, MANY OF
WHICH I WOULD SAY ARE LOOK VERY
USEFUL. AND SO MAKE THIS KIND OF
AN INTERESTING MODEL. I THINK
DEPENDING ON HOW IT GOES FOR,
YOU KNOW, OTHER SMALL DISTRICTS
TO REPLICATE BECAUSE CERTAINLY
IN RURAL AREAS THIS IS A COMMON
CONCERN. SO ANYBODY ELSE? MR.
LAIRD, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
JUST BRIEFLY? THIS HAS BEEN AN
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE FOR ME,
NOT JUST ABOUT THE STONEY CREEK
DISTRICT, BUT ONE OF THE OTHER
THREE IS IN MY DISTRICT IN BIG
SUR. IT HAS 17 STUDENTS IN A K
THROUGH 12 DISTRICT, AND IT
PRESENTS INCREDIBLE THAT, NOT
THE LEAST OF WHICH DURING THE
RAINS THE LAST TWO YEARS, THE
SLIDE CLOSED HIGHWAY ONE AND
SPLIT THE DISTRICT OF 17
STUDENTS IN HALF, SO THEY HAD TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DEAL WITH HALF
THE STUDENT BODY IS SMALL AS IT
IS, NOT HAVING ACCESS TO THE TO
THE CAMPUS, AND I THINK THAT WE
LIVE IN A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
LEGISLATIVE WORLD. AND I THINK
THIS GIVES LOCAL DISTRICTS AND I
THINK THIS WILL MAKE 4 OR 5 IF
THIS PASSES TO ALLOW DEALING
WITH THESE UNIQUE THINGS ON
THEIR OWN TERMS IN A WAY THAT
THE STANDARDS AREN'T RELAXED,
BUT THEY HAVE A WAY OF DEALING
WITH ABSENTEEISM. SO IT'S BEEN A
GOOD PROCESS, AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE
AND REAL QUICK QUESTION, IS
THERE A SUNSET ON THIS MEASURE?
I SHOULD KNOW THIS? IS THERE
ONE? IS THERE A SUNSET? WHAT IS
THE SUNSET? IT'S 20 2829. SO BY
BY THEN WE SHOULD HAVE A PRETTY
GOOD SENSE OF HOW THIS IS
WORKING. SO SUPERINTENDENT
PENNELL, THANK YOU. AND HONESTLY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR GETTING ME CLEAR ANSWERS TO
THE QUESTIONS. AND, MR. CHAIR, I
WAS NO DUMMY. THE SUNSETS THE
YEAR AFTER YOU AND I LEAVE THE
LEGISLATURE. SO THIS WILL BE FOR
OTHER. YOUR LEGACY WILL CONTINUE
ON AND ON, MR. LAIRD. SO YOU
HAVE A MOTION FROM WE. FIRST,
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM, MADAM,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. OKAY
NEWMAN HERE. NEWMAN HERE. OCHOA.
BOGH. CORTESE CORTESE. HERE
GLAZER. GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS HERE.
WILK. WILK. PRESENT A QUORUM HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED. SO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THIS MEASURE FROM
SENATOR WILK, MADAM, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON SB 1442. MOTION IS
THAT THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS BE
CONCURRED IN NEWMAN. HI. NEWMAN.
I OTOBO CORTESE. CORTESE I
GLAZER. GONZALEZ SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I WILK
WILK I. THAT MEASURE HAS FOUR
VOTES. IT IS I KNOW I TOLD FOLKS
IN ADVANCE THAT I WASN'T GOING
TO HOLD IT OPEN, BUT I'M GOING
TO GIVE SENATOR GLAZER FIVE
MINUTES, NOW, WE DO HAVE A WE
HAD A MOTION ON SB 691 SENATE-TV
PORTANTINO, BUT THANK YOU, BOTH
OF YOU, I'LL LET YOU GET BACK TO
WORK, SENATOR, AND THANK YOU FOR
BEING WITH US. SUPERINTENDENT WE
HAD A MOTION FROM SENATOR WILK
NÓ FROM CORTESE. SORRY, ON SB
SIX, 91 FROM SENATOR PORTANTINO.
MADAM CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL FOR ITEM ONE. MOTION TO
SET THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS. BE
CONCURRED IN NEWMAN. NEWMAN. I
OCHOA BOGH CORTESE. CORTESE I
GLASER. GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS I WILK.
WILK. NØ THAT MEASURE HAS THREE
VOTES. SENATE-DISTRICT OH! HOW
INTERESTING. WE'RE GOING TO HOLD
THIS OPEN. ALL RIGHT. THANKS,
EVERYBODY. LET ME. WE'LL RECESS
AND GIVE SENATOR GLAZER A CHANCE
TO COME VOTE. THANKS TO SENATOR
WILK'S VOTE. OKAY.
IS BACK IN SESSION, SENATOR
GONZALEZ IS HERE. MADAM
CONSULTANT, IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND
READING REOPENING THE ROLL AND
CALLING THE ROLL FOR HER BENEFIT.
ITEM ONE SB 691 PORTANTINO THE
MOTION IS THAT THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN
OTOBOKE GLASER, GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I ITEM NUMBER TWO, SB
1440. LAIRD. THE MOTION IS THAT
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS BE
CONCURRED IN OTOBOKE. GLASER.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. I ALL RIGHT.
SO EACH OF THOSE MEASURES HAS
ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT. THANK
YOU. AND WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR JUST A FEW MORE MINUTES
FOR SENATOR GLAZER. RECESS. ONCE
AGAIN, AS WE WAIT FOR THE LAST
MEMBER TO COME VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR GLACIER, THANK YOU FOR
COMING BY. MADAM CONSULTANT, IF
YOU WOULDN'T MIND, PLEASE,
REOPENING THE ROLL FOR SENATOR
GLAZIER. VOTE ITEM ONE SB 691
PORTANTINO. THE MOTION IS THAT
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS BE
CONCURRED IN THE CURRENT VOTE IS
4 TO 1 WITH THE VÌ WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. OTOBO. GLASER.
GLASER. I THAT MEASURE HAS FIVE
VOTES TO ONE. IT IS OUT. LAST IS
SB 1445. ITEM TWO SB 1440.
LAIRD. THE MOTION IS THAT THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED
IN THE CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE AYES
AND NOES, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. OTOBO. GLASER. GLASER. I
THAT MEASURES OUT SIX VOTES TO
ZERO. THANK YOU. THIS THIS
ADJOURNS THE SENATE OF
EDUCATION. THANK YOU.